hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dark wood now I'm
sorry for the gap in the episodes I
actually did keep recording since the
last one but I did so embarrassingly
terribly bad that it would have been a
huge embarrassment for the entire gaming
community across the world and I didn't
feel like posting it it was pretty
terrible but some people would still
want to see it so I made a little
three-minute montage of my failures so
here's that now no more Tom no don't
blow up everything ah crap that huh wow
that was stupid of me
there we go haha
ah but okay where's the well is that the
well no that's a lamp where's the well
hello Oh what is that oh what is that oh
this is sad okay okay oh oh oh I got a
plank of wood with nails in it well no I
didn't ring for the Wow
No here the plank wood Oh
oh hey hey hey listen I got a bucket you
wanna you want the bucket okay I'm just
gonna whoa hey hey whoa whoa hey da we
will whoo-hoo-hoo ever that may or may
not be I don't okay that exploded in my
face that's exactly what I didn't want
Welli well well he where am i okay thank
you thank you thank you
all right okay Jennifer god dammit you
son of a [ __ ] Oh God okay well then
clunk yeah [ __ ] you thinking in here
he's gonna put this by the window just
to further prevent anyone from getting
in through that particular entrance oh
god there's a giant hole in my wall what
am i doing Oh God Oh
oh it's good okay I'm going in here whoo
you guys oh I'm in on it
whoa boy barricaded up I know togheter
cut out going back
oh no no no god I'm an idiot wasn't that
awful
I am literally the worst but either way
I decided to start another game and yes
I did get to day seven before hell I
only survived one night one night in
that entire span I survived one okay so
I'm back in the game now I'm at a point
where I'm relatively comfortable with
what I'm doing but unfortunately
apparently it's about to turn to
nightfall I have two doses of the stuff
and I can actually throw these other
mushrooms in there but unfortunately I
don't think I have enough supplies I
could have sworn that when I was here I
didn't have this problem and also I
cannot believe how stupid I was but I
didn't even know that my well was right
there really it was right there no one
could have possibly missed that in any
fashion anywhere but either way I know
that it takes a little bit longer for
nightfall to get here so I'm gonna try
to collect just a few more supplies I'm
really hoping that nothing is gonna kill
me before I get there because I need a
few mushrooms and I need a lot more orbs
and nails to be able to board up the
rest of my house or at least a portion
of my house so that I can hold out and
nothing will hopefully kill me which is
been my biggest problem but at least my
upgrades allow me to see a little better
underneath the trees and hopefully the
normal oh oh oh it didn't see me oh it
didn't see me oh it didn't see me oh my
god what was that doing there oh okay
climbing ahead back one head back I do
not know why that guy chose to be right
there but it's almost I fall I don't
have time to think about any of those
things that's a used mushroom I got
before please tell me I didn't just lose
my house where's my house where where is
my house please oh that guy actually
asked up okay yes
oh I think I have enough to board up
another one oh it would be exactly what
I need but if things get too mean I
can't exactly do anything then oh my
face just closed that on my face there
but the stool let's see I'm gonna take
that stool in there I'm gonna drag it
over to a little bit oh I need to get
out the door don't I ain't gonna matter
a little bit also I didn't notice this
giant gap in my goddamn house
I'm gonna drag this her bitter herb
interpreter her bitter
perimeter her better ok stop dragging
drag it from the other side now hey the
dog b'doop
ok come on squidge it in there nice and
tight ok nothing will get in ever good
good enough for me but things will crawl
right in the window because I'm an idiot
okay
I saw the situation is I got these
boarded up here well the ones on the
sides boarded up and I think I have
enough to board up just one more dunk
dunk and then what I can do is I'm gonna
place a bear trap like oh wait no no
before I do that no no I need to go
drink it's time to drink I think it's
just saw it light up oh the night
sickness is getting to me yes yes yes
yes drink you lovely drinky through okay
Wow my face why do I keep doing that
what do we keep slamming doors on my
face okay so that doesn't even have a
door way that's wedged in there that
barricaded up okay I didn't turn out my
generator oh boy Hey okay still okay
nothing's gonna kill me just yet
nothing's killing me yet there we go
I don't have a lot of gas I don't know
how long that's gonna last but hey
better than nothing no key also I don't
know if that's just like a beacon of
life for everything to come kill me but
I'm gonna hopefully not have to deal
with that oh here we go
okay oh I'm out of wood I can't even
make that oh I'm so screwed I am so
screwed
err trap so figure my house why can't i
mister come on boys it come on okay okay
I'm okay I'm okay
oh I need to move this damn it I should
have moved this in front of it and put
the bear trap later I cannot think for
the life of me this is noisy what if
everyone notices this doesn't this door
open whoa hello oh god oh god oh god
that was dumb oh oh so dumb oh my oh I
can survive a night I kinda just broke
off my only escape hey no no shut up
hello already what was that what boy oh
hi hi hi hi hi hi no no no no no it's
one of them villager duties they can't
see me they don't know I'm here did he
stop cause this is nerve-racking oh he's
not stopping Jen
so the other house I think that Lee just
climbed in the window John
I saw that I saw that I saw shadow
you're walking around you're trying to
find a way in huh yeah that's what I
thought here's what I thought hi there I
see you okay okay okay
yes yes yes I survived tonight I did it
I did it everybody are you happy with me
are you happy about me no okay that's
okay I got it okay so I'm asked to
recover that okay this next day I'm
gonna be much more prepared prepared
goddamn I would go to the pig farm but I
know that dude is over there so I'm
hoping that I won't have to deal with
him he doesn't have anything so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go over to the not
that way because there's some goo bees
there I just got to be very careful when
I go into these woods because it gets a
little tense when there's the GU bees on
the ground and I don't even know what
they are but they're literally just wet
they're black they're a whole lot of
Hell okay the only way I would pile
exactly what I need so much more would I
also need to sell some stuff to the wolf
but you know the only things that I
would be able to get back from them that
I would really need our bullets and I
actually don't have a gun yet there's
every possibility that I could find one
I think anyway but I have not had that
luck yet mushrooms but be careful
the Skyler e-patient this game is about
being careful and having patience
because you are not strong even if I
have a gun I don't think I'd do very
well against some of these creatures
okay that looks like an edge of the
woods I don't want to go to there
because there might be creepy crawlies
in the woody Woody's shut up no I don't
I'm trying to stay out in the open even
the rabbits no or that's the safest
admissions
I'm gonna be fine I'm gonna be totally
fine what is that okay that's a shadowy
goobie they are being very on the open
I've not experienced them being that far
out just everywhere at least in my
limited experience in my expertise in
this game okay good more wooden more
nails I need to just get a stockpile of
wooden nails because I'm always gonna
need them for barricades and such
because I imagine then it's gonna get to
the point where they're gonna start
breaking oh no oh but what I what is
that who the hell Jesus oh just checking
out a dog wears a tank wreck what the
hell happened I got a note that said I
found a tank wreck
what the hell don't do that to me you
douches who was that
never seen someone throw a rock at me
before there's a dead body mine
my dad buck okay it was booby-trapped oh
god I point that Bay oh why why must
this happen to me why do bad things
having a good people well like me god
damn it how oh god it's gonna last a
long time isn't it tamanna Circe's he's
going in a circle they're like really
boxing me in here I can't exactly go
anywhere oh all right god damn it I
don't have anything to treat that all
the dead bodies by myself
he's betrayed me God it's not gonna kill
me oh my god that kills me I will be so
upset
we'll be so unbelievably angry come on
don't kill me please I don't have any
medicine I don't have any pills I don't
and wait do I have enough to make a
bandage please Oh God bandaged me up
because I am NOT doing okay Oh use it
use it use it use it use bandages use it
there we go
no use what I use them okay
I used them okay so they're doing their
thing I think
ye-yeah my health is going up okay I'm
good I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good
I'm solid I'm rock solid I'm good
good god that probably saved my life
because I was about to die there what a
dick move putting just a damn thing
there that will kill me goddamn dead
bodies I should not check that bodies
sure lots of much lot so much I found
the chicken lady house good I've been
looking for her forever alright let's
see what the chicken lady SS say to me
where is it Wow there it is okay who
would plan please tell me that's wood
yes and he loses so much wood that was a
lot of wood probably what this lady used
a barricade up her house I'm not gonna
pay edge of that wooden floor is sticky
with chicken feces and feathers lovely
very good lady hello oh hi there you let
me don't mind me just barging it who
recipe for an antidote chicken that is
exactly what I need to Isis I thought I
saw those a branch Thurman hello hi hi I
hope you haven't come from ideas you
bastard he puts one of the chicks is
close to her ear while maintaining eye
contact with you after a while she eases
up well good I'm glad you like me kinda
I've seen a lot I survived the wars but
the things here god help me there's no
place for chickens young man no place
for you with your nice tentacle beard
are you Davy Jones wife where did you
get this umm Holy Mother it's Jan
explain my brother a few days ago he got
angry I told him stay you're uneducated
you don't understand but he did not
listen and went looking for this man
photo of the doctor okay so that's the
doctor it looks like that dude that
makes the movies I can remember the name
of because I'm bad with names
the doctor had a wife and a kid really
some other people over there that don't
look happy but hey whatever uh take it
Janek went to see him do you understand
he never came back
find him find him and bring back my
porch it
where's Italy oh my lord is that
creature again Oh mean the violin
brought his he'll rot his he'll get the
hell on my lawn you bastard
okay uh yes normal and I'm gonna I'm
gonna finish up raiding your entire
house good enough Oh God about a pig Oh
what do I put away can I learn that can
I learn oh god damn I don't need Flair's
maybe I need a rag just in case I get
hurt again we're drunk God you have a
lot of stuff lady alcohol I have one of
those I can stack them yes okay anything
else great bat demon it's all lit up
wrong code good thing it wasn't
booby-trapped okay we'll find out about
this mysterious noise oh hi oh that's a
beautiful tune could you shut the hell
up
musician okay Wow Plus character design
going on here Oh hope you did it don't
mind my music but you don't look like
you're from around here remember maybe
through the bass the low low locals
appreciate music the boy is clearly
avoiding my sight oh that's a kid omen
dad I'm playing for the pretty lady
inside I even wrote a few songs for her
one of the strings on his mask falls off
together with his ear the boys sticks it
back on like nothing happened okay I'll
show you this well you want to see the
doctor too you know since you're here
maybe you could tell me I could give you
my place in the queue if you would help
me get back my vial
oh you're in queue to see the doctor
okay my mother is supposed to give it to
me when I was old enough but I'm big now
but my parents are very very angry with
me I want to apologize but I'm scared
they will yell at me okay I made my
mommy something pretty will you take it
to her I'm sure that she sees it she'll
stop being angry and get back my violin
and okay close by to the south of here
need to be really careful it's really
stinking out there okay what about the
dog tag oh boy
alright then goodbye okay hold the turn
cat damn I need more inventory space I
think I need to either find me I need to
drop off back at my home to drop off
some of the wood but I won't leave this
here
the bread healed me up okay I needed
that anyway okay that's good enough I'm
gonna go back to my house which is to
the north okay
out this way then I'm not drop off some
stuff maybe cook up another AA dosage of
duty daddy no okay I thought that was
alive hey don't laugh in me I know I
know it may not have seemed alive to you
guys but I'm not taking any chances I
might have enough mushrooms front rim in
inventory oh they only stack up to ten
I'll leave it there it's not like it's
going anywhere I think ten will be
enough to get me another dose
hope I don't miss my own house again
like it did before
okay I'm full up on those good good good
you poured up the rest of my die where
am I
god I wish the map showed my position
what about this road okay so it's just
to the north of this Wimbley road here
should be raha here we go okay got it
I'm good good everybody really good okay
so I still haven't found any more gas
it's kind of a problem no open then it
won't be that much of a problem okay so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna yeah I'm
just gonna cook it up okay let's cook up
let's cook up some mushroom meth and
inject it in our face add a lot more
than I thought okay whoa cool ooh
animals are more aggressive towards me
why what what do you mean what is that
see farther open your third eye for a
short amount dodge ball tweeting man
what that seems useful but right now I
don't have a melee weapon so I guess
I'll get to why would I want that oh
they are more aggressive towards me
that's the cost of that oh I get it okay
ah okay I get it I get it okay
so field if he was narrower immune
system is weakened
I guess I'll take that like the first oh
I get to choose a piss why would I want
to see farther but my odd as it seems
like a battery well I have that so maybe
uh offsets I don't know
what whoa wait a minute no you do not do
this to me I was just in my house was
that the Liberty Bell hello sound is
still vibrating inside this mossy pal
that's good
where the hell am I don't you make me go
to church you bastard
Oh bad things happen in horror games and
churches to church this in the ground
what the hell that's weird
oh hi are you Dan in line
you mean Stan's there's no line uh hell
is going on here
who the hell am I shut up outside
okay the roof is bending under the
weight of red oily clouds that doesn't
make any sense
the whole front of the building fell off
and you're telling me it's weighing down
under clouds uh hell is that okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay oh hi um
it's easy there's a line oh I'll take
that yeah that'll be that'll be good for
me Oh Rico where'd you come from
hello oh you're gone what excuse me
pardon hung open with a lockpick okay I
have one of those now looky all righty
then unlocks let's go further into this
weirdo nightmare who kill it I get what
is that about a strange box how okay I
found an axe so that's good maybe I'll
get to keep it
no Sussex guy Oh something's coming no
okay okay Gilly oh god no no just die
yeah yeah Medallia 4 2 1 set the code
861 841 Oh God Oh 8 4 2 all that sound
ok Oh what did I do
hi good tell me something
you look tired mean busy night wing Kogi
I got a strange box what is this [ __ ]
huh ok but you still want to know what's
inside a somewhere far to the south west
of here lies a place where you'll find
the key to this box but I doubt you will
know how to open it yeah I know the guy
in the photo if you want I could this
remind me do you do know I always wanted
a cat ah Lynx would be nice hey just so
happens on ok whatever we're gonna links
to me search there what I know I'm too
good for you maybe because I've got a
soft spot for cats in my heart you'll
find the links in the hunters cabin far
southeast okay so there's South West far
southwest and then this far southeast
he's to the southeast
ok I needed to trade with you anyway cuz
I don't have a gun so I figured I might
as well trade this I think the first
thing I did find a recipe to craft up um
a pellet gun so I'm hoping that how do I
trade only a few ok just shift click ok
so I'm gonna take his pellets cuz I
think maybe I'll need them in the future
guess I'll take a rag wait seems like
those things are empty why do they all
look bad ok whatever
either way I think I have what I need
maybe I don't know I don't know anything
anymore okay bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
Gone Baby Gone okay alright so I did I
do good or did I do bad I don't know
anymore uh but either way I think I'm
done for this part I've been playing for
a while so I'm just gonna leave it here
so hopefully everything will be fine in
the next episode so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done as always
I will see you in the next video
in order it didn't freeze it to me